bonjour xavier merci d'être là
bienvenue dans le cercle airs comme on
est heureux de vous recevoir en noir si
chére avec la merci pour cette émission
spéciale qui est dédié aux talents qui
ont émergé depuis la naissance du cercle
votre premier long métrage j'ai tué ma
mère date de 2009
vous avez tous les six autres films
depuis dont le tout dernier ma vie avec
john f dans nos veines qui sortira le 13
mars et vous avez par la grâce de votre
jeune âge tout l'avenir devant vous
comme nous enfin surtout comme vous
quand même chacun de vos longs métrages
a été salué ici ce qui fait de vous une
sorte de mascotte du cercle vous allez
avoir 30 ans et vous l'avez souvent dit
vous vous sentez appartenir à une
génération
comment va-t-elle cette génération
aujourd'hui à quoi pense-t-elle de quoi
rêve t elle je pense qu'elle rêve de
liberté puis d'égalité mais on parle
d'une génération d'artistes ou d'une
génération au sens plus large d'une
génération d'artistes que vous incarnez
aussi j'avoue que est entré prix avec
mes propres projets mes propres films je
vois pas toujours le le travail
spécifiquement des artistes de ma
génération je parfois oui parfois non
je suis pas toujours nécessairement à
jour j'essaie vraiment de garder un
rythme où je découvre le travail de mes
contemporains mais j'avoue que c'est
plus aléatoire c'est forcément juste des
gens de mon âge
aussi je sens que j'ai pas vraiment de
génération de cinéastes dans le monde et
artistique des individus il ya des des
genres de cinéma mais après il pas
vraiment d'âge on fait pas un film avec
avec son âge ou avec sa génération dit
que vous étiez en coulisses la tout à
l'heure que frédéric a analysé oui une
scène de laurence anyways je vais
écouter entre oui mais j'étais aussi
entraîneur p verres de contact
[Rires]
j'ai déjà j'ai vu à moitié avait
seulement avec ça doit être étrange
quand même d'entendre parler de ses
films parfois les entendre analysés par
des enseignants si ça fait ça fait ça
fait longtemps
pour moi en tout cas ça fait longtemps
que les faits vous le voyez parfois à la
télévision quand ils passent par exemple
j'ai peu télévision j'ai un écran où je
peux regarder des films vidéo pas non
plus mais j'avoue que j'ai pas de donc
s'ils passent à la télévision jeu mais
j'ai revu avant de faire mon tout
dernier film mathias et maxime j'ai revu
mais quelques-uns de mes films avec avec
avec mon ami pour pour un peu de thé
voire de douzevielle les erreurs que
j'ai surtout les erreurs qui ont été
faites qui les lélés comment peut
évidemment toujours pousser la réflexion
qui s'approfondir approfondir le travail
qu'on fait donc c'est dans ce contexte
que les revoir vous êtes dur aucun autre
baiia 1 vous êtes dur avec vous mais je
pense qu'on est toujours dur avec soi
même il faut toujours se remettre se
remettre en question puis douter et puis
c'est essentiel je pense d'eux d'être
dur avec soi même on va regarder
ensemble un extrait de votre nouveau
film puisque vous nous avez apporté une
scène de ma vie avec john f donovan
c'est votre premier film en anglais il
est interprété par kit harington jacques
tremblay natalie portman susan sarandon
entre autres et c'est une histoire
d'amitié entre un jeune garçon et son
idole une vedette de série télévisée
qu'elle sait ce que vous avez choisi de
nous montrer j'ai choisi une scène mais
si c'est un film sur l'admiration et
puis entre autres choses c'est un film
sur l'admiration puis c'est une scène de
bufori en fait de l'enfant acteur déjà
comme tremblay qui découvre le le
premier épisode de la nouvelle saison de
ce feuilleton qui il a day dans lequel
john donovan donc interprété par kit
harington joue donc il est une fabrique
devant la télévision devant devant son
idole
nous regardons nico une bouillie là on
regarde on verra
justin marshall antilles
swiss txt
je suis seulement à des fins non venez
travailler sur corner
[Musique]
aulas
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
l'admiration
xavier dolan dont nous parlait tout à
l'heure vous l'avez eu cette admiration
la folle quand vous étiez petit oui
folle surtout non oui bien sûr j'ai été
en pâmoison devant ddd des émissions de
télévision des artistes déjà écrit des
lettres - des à des acteurs des actrices
que j'admirais des chanteurs des
chanteuses jeu
oui vraiment connu d'admiration surtout
que je n'ai d'une banlieue à ses propres
est évidemment en amérique on n'a pas
les mêmes c'est pas exactement le même
genre de banlieue mais c'est vrai moi un
peu plus formaté avec des succès pour la
ville c'est moins urbain c'est un peu
plus cosy c'est et puis je vivais avec
avec avec ma mère dans une dans une
maison en briques roses puis les
émissions de la vision que je découvrais
même j'avais une télévision et les parcs
me faisait évidemment voyager et puis il
y avait aussi un fantasme évidemment
toutes sortes de préférence qui
s'exprimait à travers les personnages
que jamais le plus soul et les puits qui
était votre joseph donovan juste mais
c'était un acteur qui s'appelle giesbert
qui jouent elles ont reçu l qui
faisaient le personnage de max evans
braswell d'ailleurs le générique est une
grosse grosse copie devant une grosse
pour ce 8 juin dommages en hommage au
jeune homme et le film sort qui les
ennuis commencent légalement pour moi
c'est sûr c'est ça ressemble tellement
tellement au générique de reçoit elle
s'est vraiment cccc une copie cc et
ramon par en fait alors j'aime dans le
sac on est montré dans la cinéphilie de
notre invité et on va poursuivre avec le
fameux questionnaire du cerf qu'est ce
que vous êtes prêts à ce qu'on visite
votre cinémathèque intérieur xavier oui
ça fait très peur alors on y va visiter
mois
intime dans lequel vous aimeriez vivre
bon dieu il y en a plusieurs mais ouais
mais j'imagine que j'irai vers un os
était pas exactement votre jambe je
l'avais un jour de harry potter as
cabane un truc assez god c'est qu'un peu
c'est un univers tellement c'est comme
le meilleur de deux mondes en élégance
le raffinement la la curiosité du
réalisateur qui en même temps il ya la
magie je pense que je choisirais
forcément si j'avais le choix de vivre
dans un film évidemment j'irai vers
quelque chose comme ce qui est un petit
peu plus petit plus magique en fait qui
est plus quelques la réalité le film qui
a le plus influencé votre création
à votre avis ben j'ai souvent parlé en
fait je pense demande de monde mon amour
et mon admiration pour titanic miche pas
convaincu que c'est le film qui m'a le
plus je pense aux films comme magnolia
de piano seul loin de pikine anderson
c'est vraiment un film
la maîtrise la passion des sentiments
l'expression surtout pour moi le
l'expression de la colère féminine de
ski une femme en désarroi récente
josiane grosse ya cette scène de jeunes
autant la pharmacienne on va faire mais
s'il tend et du post-rock question piqué
très indiscret vraiment euros db et
depuis elle est le mouche métier ccc ccc
une chose qui m'a vraiment marqué qui
est un un départ pour moi même il y en a
plein d'autres il ya de sûr sur la toile
de fincher les filles de mon enfance
aussi mais c'est d'ailleurs on apprend
des je pense que c'est les films qu'on
voit très jeunes dont on absorbe
vraiment les codes puis qui définit ce
qu'ils on n'est pas les faits mais on
découvre quand on est à l'université ou
qu'on nous dise assez bien puisque c'est
elle et elle référence en cinéma je
pense que c'est vraiment ce qui imprègne
notre enfance qui définira manque il en
est donc pour moi ce serait mme
emmanuelle a gelé du très jeune pour sa
chérie depuis 15 ans xavier dolan
puisqu'on fait les 15 ans du cercle
oui quel est le film où le cinéaste qui
vous a le plus impressionné
à votre avis je dis bien impressionné
ben thomas sanderson pitié c'est quand
même hallucinant de pouvoir c'est de
pouvoir faire d'abord un blog puis de
pouvoir faire un film comme punch drunk
love de pouvoir jongler comme ça avec
avec les univers qui soit aussi
différent qui soit aussi maîtriser et
qui soit aussi toto qui soit aussi en
totaux il sait aussi entier sa salle où
il y avait une résonance qui soit aussi
entier
pour moi ce qui est extrêmement
impressionnant chez un artiste c'est
leur capacité à pouvoir être différent à
se renouveler de façon complètement
inattendu c'est leur créativité c'est
leur polyvalence
justement quels conseils est ce que vous
donneriez à un jeune cinéaste qui
commence qui débute
je vais me donner un conseil jours
difficiles ça je reformule résiderait
qu'est-ce que je me dirai à moi c'est un
peu mais parce que si je sais pas
comment s'adresser à tous et mais
j'imagine que ce que moi en tout cas
j'ai appris c'est vraiment de savoir
s'entourer en fait de de gens qui
quittent m puis qui t'encouragent
évidemment c'est essentiel jeudi paul
inverse mais qui t'aiment assez pour
critiquer quand tu quand tu es ridicule
puis avec les compliments avec la
flagornerie on et moi en tout cas je
trouve qu'on n'évolue jamais comme ça
fait toujours plaisir mais on n'évolue
jamais c'est une station vient beaucoup
de georgia o'keefe peintre américaine
qui disait c'est l'audit social fiso
créé sixième fois que la critique la
flagornerie vont pour elle dans le
succès gouttes par le même le même évier
ou le même train ou peu importe est que
l on ressent une plus grande liberté
mon conseil serait de s'entourer de gens
qui nous critiquent davantage de gens
qui louent notre notre amitié notre en
complimentant inutilement vous aviez un
film à envoyer dans l'espace pour
présenter l'humanité aux aliens qu'elle
je regarde beaucoup cet ancien veux
juste que j'ai toujours beaucoup regardé
en fait mais que je suis échangé des
coups avec la grand plaisir dernièrement
mais moi j'en verrai les visiteurs car
jusqu'à ce comme ce jeu qui pensent à
nous en faire et que ça intéresse est
menacé c'est l'image que je vais
examiner les films récents qui vous a
fait le plus de bien jusqu'à la garde de
xavier legrand oui quoi parce que je
trouve que c'est un film sera en fait
c'est un film qu'on qualifierait d'un
film à caractère social chaque fois
qu'on raconte l'histoire des problèmes
qu'on peut éprouver dans notre vie à la
maison c'est toujours on a l'impression
de voir des gens gris qui courbent
l'échiné qui baisse la crise qui marche
comme ça puis on se moque d'eux ou ont
cessé sa mangue as parlé ici c'est c'est
fait je trouve avec avec élégance
on accorde d'importance et motive on en
accorde une intelligence à tous les
personnages malgré tout et puis dans la
mise en scène aussi une force ça fait
mal tellement cccc juste puis en même
temps
ça fait aussi du bien c'est tellement
c'est tellement c'est bon puits puis
maîtrise rare d'entendre xavier parler
comme ça avec autant de passion d'un
autre cinéaste et s'est fait
complètement cessé ça faisait longtemps
que je l'avais puis c'est un plaisir je
n'ai jamais regardé le film annonce
films etc
ça se fait je me garde pour un moment
j'étais en vacances a fait avec un ami
après un pion leur garde et puis on
était on pensait se coucher je
simplement les descentes et au bar sur
le bus peuvent aller se coucher est
possible ce questionnaire n'est pas fini
je suis sûr que vous avez des questions
pour xavier tous marie-philip havas oui
moi ça concernerait la musique avec la
récente disparition de michel legrand
j'ai forcément repenser à l'ouverture de
tom à la ferme où votre personnage
chante en playback les moulins de mon
coeur et je me suis demandé si un jour
vous avez vous envisageriez de faire une
comédie musicale complètement qu'elle
coiffe et mais en fait la réalité c'est
qu'il ya pas vraiment de genre de film
que je n'envisagerais pas de faire un
jour tout m'attire que ce soit un film
de science-fiction ou un film comme un
film de super héros de marvel ou deux
pas sûr que je m'engage pas compris il
faut travailler le côté un peu plus
commerciale mais un peu plus accessible
mais oui comédie musicale ou un film de
juan harry potter ça mais ça fait
maintenant un coup les produits total et
personne ne regarde souvent trouvé la
caméra une tempête d'applaudissements
pour remercier territoire de toutes ces
confidences